can you get an election by the end of
this week
elections referendums these two men
walked instead for years through the
biggest hurdles of the modern
political era
so many times boris johnson came through
because of
one advisor permanently in the
background
all the way throughout his first 18
months in number 10.
but the strains and grudges that also
ferment behind this very door
can have consequences years after
as dominic cummings showed tonight
naming leakers
suggesting interference with internal
investigations
and most toxic of all accusations about
the costs of the refurbishment of this
flat
above number 11 that boris johnson and
his fiancee
live in in a 1 000 word blog dominic
cummings suggested that the prime
minister had been exploring ways of
getting
others to secretly pay for the lavish
makeover
a move which would break electoral law
he said i told him the prime minister i
thought his plans to have donors
secretly pay for the renovation
were unethical foolish possibly illegal
and almost certainly broke the rules on
proper disclosure of political donations
if conducted in the way he intended
at his side through the toughest of
times he now claims he watched in horror
as the pm toyed with abandoning a leak
inquiry over lockdown rules
when it pointed to a friend of his
fiancee
i told him that he could not possibly
cancel an inquiry about a leak that
affected millions of people
just because it might implicate his
girlfriend's friends
he went on to say it is sad to see the
pm and his office fall so
far below the standards of competence
and integrity the country deserves
they're calling it a nuclear dom
the man boris johnson brought in to help
him run government
launching total war against his former
employer
but the allegation that matters is that
the prime minister
wanted to bend and break the rules and
the law
that's the thing that downing street are
going to spend days having to explain
away
out on the campaign trail the prime
minister's team claimed he hadn't broken
the law
interfered in a leak inquiry and always
acted properly
but in order to be able to kick
allegations about the flat into touch
they revealed he personally has now paid
the redecoration
himself at a likely cost of 60 000
pounds
but the man himself did not want to
answer about any of it be it on how much
he had to pay for the flat or where the
money came from
all that will be declared in the normal
way and
and i'm much more interested in telling
you about the regeneration
that we're hoping to see here or we're
already seeing
in t side cheers cheers this man and his
team are hoping to make sleaze the
centerpiece of their election campaign
the allegations that dominic cummings
has levelled are very serious
and need to be investigated but look
this is just the latest
in a long line of accusations of
sleaze corruption grubby dealings
dodgy access he fights hard and he
fights dirty not everyone in the tory
party will welcome that the prime
minister has triggered this row
so close to an election